welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the trailer for termini a dark
fate has just dropped and after several
failed reboots of the franchise this
looks set to put the record straight
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the trailer as well as everything
we know about the movies so far this is
full spoilers ahead so if you want to go
into the film as blind as possible then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for quick in this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of the
Terminator Dog fate trailer Terminator
doc fate is the first film in the
franchise for a long time that sees
James Cameron the series creator back on
board as a producer though his input is
unknown completely Arnold Schwarzenegger
did stay in an interview that he was
overseeing the entire project from
scripting to beyond so it could be the
closest film to his vision that we've
had in a long time the trailer gives us
our first real look at Gabriel Luna as
the new Terminator Lewis starred as
Ghost Rider in the Marvel TV universe
and he definitely fits the role to a tee
Mackenzie Davis of Blade Runner 2049
Fame also stars in the film and they are
set to become the new series lead though
this is a heavily female led film back
in the saddle - is all swore to [ __ ]
and the actor is set to reprise his role
as the t800 once more now it's clear
that this is definitely a series
correction and those who've seen
Terminator 3 will remember that Sarah
Connor was killed off screen due to
cancer this movie looks to be ignoring
the entries in the franchise after
Terminator 2 which due to the
time-travel aspects of the series I'm
sure will be an easy cover up the
trailer opens with a road which is being
traveled down which is of course a big
motif of the movies with the characters
constantly pushing ahead into unknown
territory and this shot has been in the
majority of the films from the original
and beyond we see the two new
terminators with Gabriel Luna being made
up of Nana
similar to the one in Genesis and it's
clear that our three main characters
have teamed up with the Machine
themselves in the form of Mackenzie
Davis who will be going at odds with
this Davis is clearly having an identity
crisis though and she states that she's
human so perhaps this film will have a
hybrid say something similar to the
Terminator we saw in Salvation they are
joined by none other than Sarah Connor
wielding a huge gun and bazooka and
though she's famous to us they clearly
have no idea who she is now the thing
that can be taken from this is that John
Connor is no longer a priority with the
new female of the group apparently being
the person that has to survive the
entire ordeal perhaps Anna Burton
Judgment Day John can no longer be the
savior as the timeline has changed and
this is why the torch is being passed
both literally and figuratively there's
also an amazing airplane burst airplane
scene and yet the action in this
franchise just keeps getting bigger and
better I'm quite curious to see why John
isn't there and it may even be that the
character is dead which is why he's
unable to become the leader of the
resistance but yeah it looks really good
it's interesting that they finally wiped
all the other movies after Terminator 2
but they kind of dug themselves into a
hole a bit with Judgment Day definitely
happening and the alternate timeline so
I do think it's good that they've
decided to just go back and start after
- it worked with Halloween so I don't
really see a reason why it won't here
hopefully the franchise bounces back
like our knee getting drop kicked and we
get some more footage of him in the
movie than we got in the trailer
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer and if there's anything
that I missed comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of this week's big
movie bright burn which will be linked
at the end we've also just launched a
merchandise section on the channel so if
you want to support the videos and get
something back from it make sure you
click the links in the boxes below this
is the channel for people who were mad
into movies so if that's the kind
in you like hit subscribe thanks again
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you